so
last week
republican congressman madison cawthorne
the freshman lawmaker and senior
douchebag got in hot water about
statements he made on a podcast
cawthorne claimed that since he's been
in washington he has been invited to
multiple orgies by older lawmakers he
said
i've always paid attention to politics
guys that you know
then all of a sudden you get invited to
like hey we're going to have kind of a a
sexual get together at one of our homes
you should come they're like
what did you just ask me to come to yeah
and then you realize they're asking you
to come to an orgy yeah
these are very serious accusations
to think that these senior politicians
who make laws for our country are having
group sex all i can say is
gross
[Music]
that [ __ ] is gross
the image of old white people having
group sexes gross
so
my question is why would you put that
image in our heads are you hoping we
won't show up to the polls because we're
too busy throwing up at the thought of
chuck grassley and mitch mcconnell and
icewide shut mess
i mean
[Applause]
seeing those two guys in eyes wide shut
mess that's just
gross
that [ __ ] is gross
none of those people are fine we're
living in the worst timeline cause that
[ __ ] is gross
can you imagine
walking into a room and seeing a
sexually aroused ted cruz
[Applause]
i'm sorry this is part of it
you guys
the only way to describe that
is
[Music]
gross that [ __ ] is gross
[Music]
the very thought of it is rotten the
image of a naked tonka and it's
gross
[Applause]
in a response to the blowback he
received hawthorne said my comments on a
recent podcast appearance calling out
corruption have been used by the left
and the media to disparage my republican
colleagues and falsely insinuate their
involvement in illicit activities
[ __ ] you disparaged your republican
colleagues
the left in the media didn't make you go
on a podcast and talk [ __ ] about your
homies
you talked about that [ __ ] willingly you
did
what you didn't talk about in that
podcast are all the allegations of
sexual harassment against you from
multiple people you went to college with
so don't try to take the moral hiro when
you out there doing dirk because you
representative madison
cawthorn you are
gross
instead of voicing your discontent talk
more about getting women's consent
you're as gross as the former president
grossness is all you really represent
you
are
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you